كان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتربريكن قد
قال ان بلاده ملتزمه بالسياسه الباب
المفتوح امام الدول الراغبه في الانضمام
واضاف بلنكن في مقابله مع سي ان ان
اوكرانيا احرز التقدما لنيل عضويه الحلف
ولكن يجب عليها القيام بالمزيد من
الاجراءات مثل اصلاح جيشها وتعميق
الاصلاحات الديمقراطيه وفق تعبيره
ملتزمون بما يسمى سياسه الباب المفتوح
للنيتو والترحيب بالاعضاء الجدد عندما
يكونون مستعدين للعضويه ويوافق كل الحلفاء
على انضمامهم اوكرانيا احرز التقدما جيدا
في هذا الاتجاه وهذا سيظهر في هذه القمه
لكن في الوقت ذاته فان الاوكرانيين وغيرهم
يعترفون بان امامهم المزيد من العمل
والاستمرار في اصلاح جيشهم والتعميق
الاصلاحات الديمقراطيه قمه ستقدم حزمه
قويه من الدعم السياسي والعملي لكييف
ومزيدا من التقدم نحو عضويه النيتو